pendant douze heures vous êtes comme un
couple royal si les médias qui font
monter la sauce voulez mais beaucoup
david beckham est très amoureuse de lui
c'est vrai que vous l'avez ses shorts
c'est sa femme comment on voit les
mariés vivent droit pourquoi et marié tu
comprendrais très bonne laver les skins
de son mari bah ouais voilà mon celi ont
péri est-ce que vous la verriez les
suisses de votre mari non mais ne vous
serez jamais mariés bézy mais mettra pas
cela alors concertés avec avec monsieur
de boeuf mais mes thierry vous êtes vous
êtes vous ne mettez pas de slip donc
elle peut vivre le match démarre vite -
vitoria
il ya une question qui est très célèbre
dans cette émission c est ce que par
amour vous embrasse seriez sans fois les
chaussettes sales de votre amoureux
c'est la question clotilde courau voilà
que les habitués des missions
connaissent bien il voulait que je fasse
oui oh la la
la plume est comme ça j'étais tatouer je
me fais la tuer pour lui prouver que je
la mets donc savez les chaussettes sales
c'est pas trop dur à faire tard ou
ironie fait les chaussettes à ma femme
j'irai pas si ma femme très jolies
pièces en mouvement des pieds je pense
pas que enfin bon bah oui c'est ça
l'amour enfin gap non je crois qu'il
faut je crois qu'il fallait au bout de
l'histoire
on va faire une interview par amour
pendant le génial
très bien est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à arrêter de chanter oui
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous convertir à l'islam
oh non non non non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
le visage par un chirurgien esthétique
mais la vie est ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à prendre 20 kg oui il
fallait parce que par amour c'était vous
seriez prête à vous déguiser en elton
john je sais c'est dur mais bon quand on
aime quelqu'un en même temps tout ce
qu'il voudrait que je fasse je le ferais
là est-ce que par amour
si ça le rendait heureux vous seriez
prête à accepter qu'il ait une maîtresse
non non vous l'aimez pas vraiment alors
ça veut dire que je peux pas partager
quelques uns plus jeune quand on n'a que
l'amour c'est quelque chose de
réciproque café l'écossé mais qu'elle
pourrait en fait avoir du respect de
l'amour et s'il avait une maîtresse ça
voudrait dire qu'il me
ça va est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à devenir son esclave sexuelle
would you be comme sex voix et vous mais
peut-être il est lui-même bon disque là
c'est ça l'histoire
et toi franck moi je suis l'esclave
sexuelle de ma femme quand elle veut
voilà
non mais